Speaker 1: OK, let's jump into a few other
things here, Sean Hannity, the Fox News host
and propagandist friend of Trump, he's refusing
to say whether he has been vaccinated against
covid-19.
And I have some thoughts as to why he's doing
this.
So we're going to listen to this.
This is audio from Sean Hannity's radio program.
I think that to some degree, Hannity is in
a weird place now where he's kind of depressed
that the guy he cozied up to for four years
lost and is out of power.
And increasingly, people are no longer paying
attention to Hannity either.
So I think there's a bunch of things going
on.
But let's jump in here, listen to Sean Hannity
and talk about why he's saying what everybody
Speaker 2: knows about mask's.
Right?
Everyone knows about social distancing.
Everybody knows the vaccines available pretty
much now to anyone.
If you're over 16, everybody knows what level
of risk they want to take.
Look, my attitude is, you know, do your studying
know the science to the best that we can even
say we have science involved in any of this.
Speaker 1: So so that's kind of that aside
where they love to throw in the idea that
because our understanding of certain aspects
of the virus have changed over the last 14
months, can we ever really trust anything
that's coming from the scientific community?
And this is part of this is part of the virtue
of science that science has.
Science is a process that is self-correcting,
where there are rewards for correcting information
that previously we misunderstood.
And and, in fact, that should make us trust
more in the process.
OK, let's continue, because
Speaker 2: they've gotten so much wrong.
The great Dr. Fouche has been wrong so often.
Speaker 1: OK, so maybe I should have played
that first before mentioning.
But again, the fact that Foushee early said
one thing about masks, but then for the last
12 months has been saying the same thing.
That's not a reason to discount what the medical
science community tells us.
Speaker 2: And the only thing I would ask
everyone is to be considerate of other people,
especially older people, those with compromised
immune systems.
Comorbidities, yeah, grandma, grandpa, mom
and dad.
Speaker 1: And and if by that he means even
if you are not at high risk, get vaccinated
to protect them, then I'm with him.
I'm not sure if that's what he means.
Speaker 2: So that if, you know, at this point,
I would assume that they're probably vaccinated,
but least to have the opportunity to get it.
If they didn't, if they should.
And that's another thing.
Why do you have to answer the question?
Well, if you got no vaccine yet, which vaccine
did you get?
How about it's none of your business?
How about.
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, you don't people
it's called making conversation.
It's also I mean, listen, right now, if my
friends want to gather indoors, I ask if they're
vaccinated and I say we're only doing indoor
stuff with vaccinated people right now other
than very Spino unvaccinated.
But work from home because I'm vaccinated,
OK?
It seems like a responsible question to be
asking.
You can decline to answer.
Speaker 2: I mean, you're not going to get
vaccinated.
How about that's a choice between an individual
and a doctor?
I'm very pro science.
I'm not anti vaccine, but I'm also medical.
I also am a libertarian believer in medical
privacy.
It's unbelievable.
Everyone wants to know
Speaker 1: medical privacy applies to practitioners
and it applies to records.
And it's not about nobody can ask.
I mean, essentially, you know, he he's almost
saying you shouldn't even be be allowed to
say, how have you been doing lately?
This is not what medical privacy means.
Speaker 2: It's like everyone.
Now, I'll tell you, I probably would have
told people my decision until everyone started
demanding that I tell them what my decision
is.
Right.
Well, my advice to everybody is research long
and hard on everything you can get your hands
on and you can read the medical literature.
Then I would look at your special and unique
medical conditions.
See this?
Speaker 1: This is really stupid because first
of all, it's not really that difficult to
figure it out.
Secondly, looking at your specific situation
is, again, the kind of Joe Rogan thing from
earlier of if you're not at risk, maybe you
don't get vaccinated.
And if you read everything that's out there,
as he suggests, a lot of what's out there
is anti vaccine trash.
And that's what a lot of his viewers are finding
on their Facebook accounts,
Speaker 2: your health and talk to the doctor
doctors that that take care of you.
Speaker 1: Or again, sure, ask your doctor.
Most people don't need to have a conversation
with their doctor about whether they should
get vaccinated.
Speaker 2: Doctor, doctors that you respect
in life and make an informed decision, and
that is that that's got to be an individual
decision.
And there are there people that have had reaction
to the fact.
Yup, should you read about that, too?
Yes, you should read it all.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think it's good to understand
the level of risk with with getting vaccinated,
which is extraordinarily low and in all cases
lower than the risk of getting the virus.
But that's fair.
You should know that one in one point two
million of the people that got the JMJ, women
age 18 to 48 had a blood clot.
Maybe if you're in that group, you opt for
a different vaccine.
If that's a degree of risk that concerns you.
I agree with that.
Speaker 2: No, I'm not.
How do I how can I possibly weigh in on whether
everybody needs to be vaccinated?
I don't know.
People's individual medical conditions.
That is not my decision.
That's your decision.
You have the right to make your own decision.
You can take whatever level of risk you might
want to take.
I just asked gently think of other people
and especially the those that would be more
susceptible for the worst outcome in all of
this.
Speaker 1: So some of what he's saying is
OK, but then also when his refusal to say,
I would have told people my vaccination status
until everybody started asking that to me,
sounds like a cop out where Sean Hannity was
vaccinated.
He doesn't want to say it because saying it
will anger the anti vax people in his audience
much more than not saying anything will anger
the vaccinated people in his audience.
It just feels like a calculation to me.
And interestingly, this isn't that dissimilar
from what Donald Trump did in the sense of
Trump was vaccinated at the White House in
January.
He didn't mention it.
He said nothing and then months later went
out of office.
He said, oh, yeah, I did receive it.
Or it was it was announced by his office that
he received it at the White House.
It strikes me as a calculation more than it
is about so-called medical privacy, but really
strange stuff happening over on the Hannity
program.
And bottom line, I think Hannity is kind of
depressed that his guy is no longer in office
and people are paying a lot less attention
to him than they used to be.
He's getting no more rides on Marine One,
but make of it what you will.